peace can be achieved today if Vladimir
Putin removed his troops from Ukraine if
he ceased this unprovoked illegal brutal
full-scale invasion of Ukraine so I
think it sounds rather Hollow coming
from a representative of the Russian
government to suggest that anyone else
is responsible for this conflict other
than Vladimir Putin himself
so in terms of talking between the UK
and Russia there are no talks on the
table that's not something that the
government's interested in pursuing in
trying to bring an end to the war
well no we absolutely do want to bring
an end to this war but what we want to
do is make sure that Ukraine's
sovereignty is respected that the UN
Charter is respected
the the Russian Federation Vladimir
Putin sent tanks has sent missiles had
sent troops into Ukraine is attempting
to brutalize that country we should
never lose sight of that and as I say
this conflict this war could come to an
end today if if Russia were to withdraw
its troops okay let's talk interest
rates really big day to day we're
expecting that announcement from the
bank of England and some suggestion that
the interest rate could go from 4.5 to
4.75 today could jump as high as 5 is
the Bank of England pursuing the right
course in putting up interest rates this
will be the 13th time and it's not
worked so far
well we know that the bank of England is
independent in its decision making with
regard to interest rates obviously it
has an inflation Target which it needs
to pursue and of course we are seeing
inflation in significant part because of
the upward pressure on food and fuel
prices which are being Amplified by this
uh war in Ukraine so the bank of England
is independent and and will make a
decisions accordingly but the Prime
Minister has made it one of the
government's priorities and all of us
across government are working towards
this which is to which is to you know
bring down inflation bring down interest
rates to help those hard-working
families afford their monthly bills and
that's what we are relentlessly focused
on yeah you talk about the bank of
England having its Target but as you
said the Prime Minister has his Target
as well one of his five pledges was to
halve inflation by the end of the year
that doesn't look on track and the bank
of England isn't helping him out so at
what point does the government step in
we have the transport secretary on
Sophie ridges program last night here on
Sky News saying that look you know the
bank of England didn't see it coming
Rishi sunak back when his was Chuck he
was Chancellor was saying that inflation
is a priority the bank of England at
that time was saying inflation's only
temporary you know let's not overreact
well look the you know the prime
minister of course has a huge wealth of
uh experience from his time as a
Chancellor as you say he cautioned about
the implications of inflation which is
why we have been so determined not to do
the things that drive up inflation and
that's in stark contrast with what we
see from the labor party who are talking
about uh inflation busting pay Rises
driven by their union pay masters it's
we hear them talking about huge huge
huge sums of additional borrowing which
would inevitably push up interest rates
even further so the prime minister is
absolutely right on that commitment and
we are still is his focuses
extremely frustrated that he's not
getting what he wants and it seems the
bank of England isn't helping him
achieve that Target should the bank be
doing more we've got Adam Posen in the
telegraph today saying that Banks should
be going further and creating a
recession what do you think about that
is the recession the answer to busting
inflation is this now the best worst
option to get the country out of this
mess
now what we need to do is we need to
grow the economy High interest rates
don't help with that this idea that
um you know that we should consciously
be going into a recession I don't think
is one that anyone in government would
be comfortable subscribing to at all
what we want to do is we want to drive
productivity this is why the the prime
minister is taking both the immediate uh
measures and also the long-term measures
his commitment to maths lifelong
learning uh higher skilled Workforce
these things will increase productivity
that will help grow the economy that
will help halve interest rates as we
have committed to do we are relentlessly
focused on getting a grip of these
global economic challenges and of course
we're seeing interesting
to make in light of what's going to
happen with the bank of England today
you're saying High interest rates don't
help which is
which is why
which is why the Prime Minister the
government as a whole is committed to
driving down those interest rates
halving those interest rates growing
there how are they going to do that how
are they going to do that let's talk
about some practical measures because
someone always profits from a crisis and
and in this point in time it's the banks
a labor have come out with a plan today
and they're talking about forcing
lenders to do more to help people with
their mortgages and there's also been
this idea muted of a windfall tax on
banks because they're having huge
profits off borrowers and they're not
really passing those on to Savers so by
the nature of that they're sitting on
huge profits should there be a windfall
tax on the banks to help in this current
situation
well the chancellor has and will
continue to meet with the financial
service industry particularly those
lenders to make sure that they are doing
the right thing by their customers now
obviously the relationship between A
bank's customers and the bank is a is a
commercial relationship between uh
between them but the government is
absolutely making sure that the
financial services industry is doing the
right thing by their customers
providing flexibility where needed by
the customer and possible by the lender
this is what this is what we are doing
to address the immediate issue but
ultimately what this is about is about
making sure we see growth back in the UK
economy we see that inflation at halving
we see debt reducing these are the
economic uh priorities that the
government has got this is what we're
working on and again I do remind viewers
that labor come out with uh what are
only ever mental to be headline grabbing
ideas they are not implementable in the
real world because if we if if we
started following the labor solution to
these problems it would make inflation
worse it would make hard working
families
about those measures so so I I will talk
to them about that and and and underline
that um just a final Point um you're
missing on Monday uh for that vote on
the Privileges committee report you
didn't vote why didn't you and if you
have been there how would you have voted
well look uh the sad truth is being a
foreign secretary and I can't remember
exactly what was in my diary at that
point in time but because I uh travel a
lot because I have a lot of commitments
with the International Community uh here
in the UK it is often the case that I
miss votes okay A lot of people are
saying it's quite funny that the Prime
Minister foreign secretary the Home
Secretary and the chancellor we're all
really busy on that Monday a lot of
people say it's quite convenient and you
know we're also
turning up for a really important vote
about democracy and Truth how would you
have voted
the point is to a large extent that vote
was a moot point it was about the
sanctions on a person who had at that
point already stood down as a as a
member of parliament now the leader of
the House made it very clear uh that we
respect the work of the Privileges
committee ultimately
positions is your friendship with Boris
Johnson men standing up for the
Democratic process you know the
Privileges committee found that former
prime minister I was in the middle of
Arts
so I was in the middle of answering
um I was I was literally in the middle
of answering when you cut me off uh the
point that uh so the point that you've
made where you're highlighting
government positions this was a free
vote this was House business it's not
government business it's not whipped and
it's down to uh individuals as I say uh
the leader of the House said how
important uh the work of the Privileges
committee was as I say I felt to a large
extent the vote was a a moot point
because the person involved had left the
house
um and therefore
against the other work that I was going
to do
foreign
secretary thank you very much uh for
answering our questions here on
breakfast